house democrats will vote to impeach the
president today
again with just one week left before his
term expires and i for one
am almost happy that the vote is
happening not because
the president should be impeached but
because it's exposing which republicans
are wise
which republicans are stupid and which
republicans are downright frauds
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday comes from
misanthropic perspective
who reminds us of a quote by dante
alighieri
which is that there is no greater sorrow
than to recall in misery
the times that we're happy i think i
think we're all going to be thinking of
that soon
we are now down to the last week of
president trump's term
after that the clampdown is going to be
absolutely brutal
and we're going to close our eyes amid
the persecution and remember the
funniest of the tweets
and that will give us both a little bit
of joy but also
add add to the misery to remember how
happy things
once were but we can still enjoy it for
a few more days
then then unfortunately probably the
the hammer will fall it's going to cut
away all of our fun
if you want to cut away all of your
unwanted stubble you should go check out
harry's razors harry's is a return to
the essential
quality craftsmanship at a fair price
how do they do it
harry's team combined a simple ergonomic
design with five sharp blades
they source their steel from sweden and
manufacture their blades in their
world-class factory in germany they cut
out the middleman and ship
directly to you saving you money and a
trip to the store
harry's stands behind the quality of
their blades so much
that they have a 100 money back
guarantee on harry's dot com
this is the best shave i've ever had
a really really great stuff very simple
harry's has a special offer for
listeners
on my show new customers can get a hairy
starter set
for just three dollars at harry's dot
com slash
knowles you will get a five blade razor
weighted handle foaming shave gel with
aloe and a travel cover
which i really appreciate because
sometimes it rips up your travel case
use the travel cover all for just three
bucks get everything you need for a
close comfortable shave go to harrys.com
knowles to claim your offer you know how
much i love harry's best shave i ever
had
go check him out
the house democrats want to impeach
the house democrats have wanted to
impeach since trump came down the
escalator at trump tower
and announced he was running for
president then they tried to impeach him
over
the russia hoax then they tried to
impeach him over his taxes then they
wanted to impeach him
over stormy daniels then he want they
wanted to impeach him over
what kind of eggs he had for breakfast
now they wanted to impeach him
for a long time they actually admitted
this al green
the congressman not the musician said in
2017
we've got to impeach him because
otherwise he might win re-election so
that they'd come to the conclusion they
wanted to impeach him before they
figured out what they would impeach him
for
finally they tried to impeach him uh
over what was it ukraine or some
nonsense i don't know whatever
and uh that didn't work now they're
going to try to do it again over this
capitol hill
riot but it's not just democrats there
are some republicans
who want to impeach him as well and i'd
i'd like to draw a distinction here i
think there are it's not just two
categories of republicans
on impeachment the you know the terrible
awful
stupid cynical ones who want to impeach
him
and the good virtuous ones who don't
want to impeach him it's actually three
categories
i think there are some republicans who
want to who sincerely think trump should
be impeached
then i think there are some republicans
who don't think he should be impeached
but cynically want to do it because they
want to keep him from running for office
again
and then i think there are the
republicans who are the
good category who realize that this is a
very very bad
idea but it's three and you've got to
kind of parse out which ones
fall into which uh one of the first
prominent republicans to say trump
should be impeached
is chris christie who was a former trump
rival in the
in the 2016 primaries then he was a
trump ally
then he was a trump rival again he went
on george stephanopoulos show on abc
and he said absolutely what trump did is
an impeachable offense
i think they're all gonna have to vote
their conscience and
and look at what happened i mean what we
had was an incitement
um to riot at the united states capital
we had people killed
uh and to me there's not a whole lot of
question here so you know so you think
it was an impeachable offense before
jordan
oh sure yeah and and you'd vote to i
think that
you know in the well that's if i think
it's an impeachable offense that's
exactly what i would do george but i'm
not in there
but you want my opinion that's my
opinion i i don't i think if
if inciting to insurrection isn't then i
don't really know what is
so that's the charge right inciting to
insurrection but as we covered on the
show yesterday
does anybody seriously believe that you
could play president trump's words
look at president trump's actions and
say that he was inciting an insurrection
the best evidence they have is that he
was giving a rally
on the national mall before they all
went over to the capitol
and he said i know a lot of people are
going to march to the capitol and we got
to be strong and we got to be peaceful
so if you if you say explicitly stay
peaceful
you how are you going to prove that
that's inciting an insurrection
you might say it was unwise you might
say he unleashed a mob
but you can't say that he was calling
for an insurrection
his own words contradict that charge now
what's going on with christy here maybe
he sincerely believes that
or maybe he's upset that he was
initially in the inner circle for trump
and then he kind of got pushed out of
the inner circle and then he got brought
in then he's pushed out and then
who knows there are a lot of internal
politics
in trump world that play into this i
mean there's this personal connection
of chris christie is the guy who threw
trump's son-in-law jared kushner's
father in prison
for financial crimes and then the father
got pardoned and then who knows i assume
there was
some bad blood there there are these
personal aspects
as well what about the other people what
about the other conservatives
or republicans i should say who are
calling for this
uh republican representative john catko
someone i've never heard of i
i guess he's a sort of backbencher
congressman he was
the first republican to come out and say
yes we should
impeach trump and you know democrats
always seem to get some useful idiot
republican
to go along with their schemes it rarely
happens the other way
whenever republicans want to do
something they rarely get a democrat
defector certainly
it's very rare to get a democrat
defector who would who would matter who
would actually change
the result but the democrats always seem
to get it for the with the republicans
because the republicans are not
particularly unified
after john catko came out and said yeah
i think we should impeach
we had another one liz cheney liz cheney
daughter of
former vice president dick cheney liz
cheney says absolutely
we should impeach that's very
frustrating and i
i suspect these people are going to pay
for that with the base in primaries who
knows
but they got an even more prominent
person when you get a republican with
the last name cheney obviously that
carries some weight in the party
but according to the new york times it's
not just catko and cheney
mitch mcconnell is reportedly pleased as
well now when you say
according to the new york times what
that means is
take everything that follows with a very
very large
like boulder-sized grain of salt
but you have the new york times
reporting you have other people as well
you even have some conservatives
reporting this mitch mcconnell is said
to be pleased
that trump could be convicted in the
senate
house would vote to impeach the senate
then could vote to convict
and then president trump would not be
able to run for office
ever again any sort of office mayor of
new york
town supervisor of palucaville or
president again in 2024.
according to these reports mitch
mcconnell is pleased because it will
help
purge the republican party of trump
and trumpism and the trump elements
now is this is this a possible
applausable rather report i think so
yeah
early on mitch mcconnell after the
election said yep joe biden is the
president-elect
and congratulations to him mitch
mcconnell has sometimes worked with
trump especially on the judges
sometimes he has not worked with trump
he is a real power broker he's been
around for a long time
and he certainly represents a wing of
the republican party that donald trump
does not represent fortunately though
some
smarter cooler heads seem to be
prevailing within the party
namely dan crenshaw dan crenshaw just
went on hugh hewitt's show
and was asked his opinion about
impeachment
and grandshaw you know dan has has
criticized trump
when he's felt those criticisms are
merited but he said absolutely not this
is a very
very bad idea for the country as a
matter of prudence and as a matter of
law
there's no reason to impeach i do
understand the precedent
argument um you know
impeachment i mean just by by the letter
of the law can be as frivolous as you
want it to be it is indeed a political
process
um i i think i think precedents are
being thrown out the window left and
right these days
um but again i i just think that the
there's two there's two reasons here um
one is simply lower the temperature the
second is
if you're going to accuse somebody of
incitement of violence that's a very
hard legal
standard to prove um there's no way it
could be proven in the court of law
in this particular case and um
you know barring that and then again the
fact that we've only got ten days
left and the thing is the priority that
we need to be engaging in is unifying
the country not
not escalating things further um
these are all pretty good reasons i
think to not not vote for
impeachment thank you thank you that's
obviously true
dan makes a point here that you don't
hear a lot of other lawmakers making
maybe because they don't even know
that this is the case impeachment is not
simply or not merely a political process
obviously it's very political you've got
congressmen voting on it and then the
jury the people who are going to vote to
convict or acquit are in the senate
however it's also a legal process
you need to commit a high crime or
misdemeanor
to be eligible for impeachment right
there is a legal criteria now
how how far do we push it toward the
legal side of things
how far do we allow it to flow into the
political side of things
that's a matter that's been up for
debate for many
years for centuries now but surely there
is a political criterion
and if there is a political criterion
what crime are you accusing the
president of committing
i don't know they're saying incitement
to violence okay well you just we played
the clip yesterday
we've played it for several days now he
says be
peaceful tim scott senator tim scott has
also said it's a dumb idea
republican joe manchin who's a sort of
conservative-ish
democrat has said that it's a bad idea
to impeach
so it doesn't seem like there is a ton
of support
for impeachment i'll give you my view
donald trump should not resign
the house should not impeach the senate
should not convict the republican
legislators
who sincerely support impeachment are
naive
and imprudent the republican legislature
laters who cynically support impeachment
are frauds they're obviously not
conservatives and i guess they're by
definition frauds right they're
deceiving you
this is a bad idea no good would come of
it even if you think trump
played some role in the capitol hill
riot even if you don't like the cut of
his jib and you don't like his tweets
which he now can't send because some
billionaire oligarchs in silicon valley
can censor the duly elected sitting
president
even if there is nothing to be gained
by the impeachment it will only rip the
country apart further
there is a lot to be lost at this very
tense moment
and there is no legal basis for
impeaching him
just as a purely rational matter
looking at the evidence on the table
there is no reason to do it
a lot of people want to do it because it
serves their political agenda and i
think we should remember those people
as we work to reconfigure the republican
party
in the coming years if you need to
reconfigure your car
i would highly recommend you head over
to rockauto
you know i love rock auto great place
family owned
been been serving customers for 20 years
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts for instance let's say
hypothetically
i'm just coming up with this on the spot
because i'm such a great car expert you
know
uh let's say you needed a delphi fg1456
fuel pump assembly you know
which is used on the 2005-2010 honda
odyssey
and it costs i don't know let's say 354
dollars at the big chain store
well that's the kind of thing you could
get at rock auto for 217 bucks that's
pretty good that's a lot of money saved
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years great selection
reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go there right now
to rockauto.com see all the parts
available for your car
or truck then write knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
and then they will know that we
sent you go to rockauto.com if you want
to fix up your car
or truck can't beat them
when i say that the republicans who
sincerely
support impeachment are naive and
imprudent
what i mean is they first of all they
don't understand
the legal basis of impeachment but two
they don't understand the political
climate that we're in
they think that they're going to get
brownie points from the left they think
we're all playing by the same standard
we're not they think that that trump's
role in incitement
was particularly egregious his role in
quote-unquote incitement
is absolutely nothing compared to the
role that
elected democrats and media figures
played in encouraging and supporting
and providing material support for the
blm riots that have been going on for a
year
including the vice president-elect
kamala harris who raised money to bail
the rioters out of prison
out of jail i suppose i hope they go to
prison
very naive they they're playing a game
where they're going to suck up
to the left and maybe they sincerely
think we can all come together and sing
kumbaya
ain't going to happen ain't going to
happen i think if you want to know
the state of the the two sides in
american politics right now
take a listen to msnbc's coverage of
president trump's most recent
press conference where he goes out he's
answering questions from reporters
and he's answering questions about his
role in the capitol hill riot
what is your role in what happened at
the capitol what is your personal report
so if you read my speech and many people
have done it and i've seen it both
in the papers and in the media on
television
it's been analyzed and people thought
that what i said was totally appropriate
and if you look at what other people
have said politicians at a high level
about the riots during the summer the
horrible riots in portland and seattle
and various other
other places we are coming out of this
now because the president has started to
uh as he occasionally does often does
veer away from the truth his video that
he taped
on wednesday after the riots were
happening at the capitol was not viewed
widely as totally appropriate in fact
many people argued they were highly
inappropriate
there is so much here that 40 second
clip
could provide a true master class in
politics
from both sides from both sides because
both sides are engaging in the exact
same tactics
obviously they have different substance
they're advocating different points of
view but they're
using the exact same tactics so you open
up with classic trump
he's being very vague right he says look
a lot of people saw my speech
okay a lot of people talked about it
everybody was analyzing it a lot of
people said
very very appropriate that's what all
the people were saying it was said about
my speech
that is what people were said to have
said about my speech and it's all vague
and he's not talking about anyone in
particular
he's not talking about any moment in
particular classic trump right and you
say well that's
terrible and we need to get more
specific that we got to purge that kind
of trumpist rhetoric from our
political dialogue then trump brings up
the blm riots and what happens msnbc
cuts away right away
and then the lady on msnbc says uh the
president
is he's lying he's absolute he says that
his
speech was widely viewed as appropriate
it was actually widely viewed as
inappropriate and everybody's talking
about it okay and it's been analyzed
okay and people are saying a lot of
things okay
she sounds just like trump except from
the other side
she's not pointing to specific examples
she's not
pointing to the words in his text she's
not
referring to the specific analysts who
said it was inappropriate
it's just the same thing the place that
the
the entire segment teeters is
trump describing the capitol hill thing
then he makes the crucial point
compare this to blm oh we got to cut
away
hold on msnbc was perfectly fine to
cover the president's remarks before he
made that point
why did they cut away because it's a
good point because it's the crucial
point
because it's the only point if you're
talking about
censure or impeachment or comparing the
two parties
one party donald trump whipped up his
supporters in a rally
and he said be peaceful and
there was some violence for a few hours
another party whipped up their
supporters into a frenzy
and said don't be peaceful chris cuomo
said protests don't need to be peaceful
hillary clinton said you can't be civil
with a political party that disagrees
with you
maxine waters said go to republicans
homes get up in their face
you get up on them in public
all prominent democrats just about
encouraging the blm riots
and msnbc and cnn standing in front of
burning buildings saying these protests
are mostly peaceful
there's there's the point and then the
minute you bring this up they say that's
what a baptism
what about it well what about it lady
that's why she cuts away and then
engages in the exact same tactics
and these squish republicans liz
cheney how disappointing i know there
are a lot of republicans who reflexively
attack the cheney family or the bushes
or something
i i don't do that i don't reflexively
attack the chinese and i think get a
kick out of dick cheney a lot of the
time
how disappointing that liz cheney would
do something like that
it's pathetic really either
she's cynical here in attacking trump
or she's incredibly naive and exercising
incredibly poor judgment either way
does not does not speak highly of her
political activities
the left is about to get very harsh on
the right
it's already happening you're going to
see a very significant
curtailment of the rights civil
liberties
it's already happening right you were
told
you can go out and mob for blm and go
loot gucci stores but you're not allowed
to go to church and you're certainly not
allowed to have conservative rallies
but that's that's just one example of a
double standard
leftists are allowed to encourage
violence on twitter
the ayatollah is allowed to encourage
violence onto genocide on twitter
but conservatives are not allowed to
i don't just talk about anything i don't
know the rules are so opaque
we don't know they seem to be changing
every day certainly it's a harsher
standard
whatever that standard is social medias
is the clearest place for this and
you know it's not just twitter twitter's
been the harshest facebook
kicked trump off youtube kicked trump
off instagram kicked trump off
allegedly for inciting violence well
instagram took a hit the head of
instagram adam moseri
was asked about this they said are you
are you now just a big liberal company
or you just you know you're going to
promote liberals and you're going to
attack conservatives and he came out and
made a statement
we're not neutral no platform is neutral
we all have values and those values
influence the decisions we make
we try and be apolitical but that's
increasingly difficult
particularly in the us where more and
more are polar where we are more and
more polarized
there's a lot here and he's obviously a
little philosophically confused
but he's mostly right he's confused but
he's mostly right and at least he's
being honest right
he's saying of course we're not neutral
no platform can be neutral
you know much as conservatives want to
push this idea that we support free
speech and we don't think that anything
should be discouraged or prohibited
that's not true that's never been true
of conservatives or of anybody else
every society has standards
we permit certain speech we don't permit
other speech
we don't permit people to be to
make seditious speech at various times
in american history we don't permit
people to make
threats we don't permit people to use
fighting words
in public we don't permit people to
engage in obscenity
though now we incur we permit that a lot
more but historically we haven't
permitted that
we don't allow people to engage in fraud
generally
at various times in american history we
don't allow people to desecrate the
american flag now it seems we encourage
it but
for a lot of american history we didn't
there are always standards and we're
sort of setting these standards
instagram's saying yeah of course we
have standards everybody has to have
standards
no platform is neutral then he says we
try to be apolitical
which means he just doesn't understand
what politics is politics
means the stuff we do in public that's
the basic definition of politics
politics comes from the word for the
greek city state it's how we all get
along together
in society since we try to be apolitical
you can't be apolitical by definition if
you're a public company
i think what he what he's trying to get
at is we try to be non-partisan
we try to not pick the democrats over
the republicans but then he admits he
says that's
increasingly difficult particularly in
the u.s
why is it difficult because because you
don't like the conservatives that's why
and because your values that you admit
that you have
lead you naturally to form a conclusion
there's this lie of liberalism that
we're all supposed to be skeptical
forever
we all need to just bill buckley writes
about this in god and man at yale
this lie of liberalism that we're all
supposed to just keep our minds
perfectly open
and even doubt our own views as we're
engaging in action
and buckley makes the point even though
many people who invoke buckley today
would disagree with this but buckley
makes the point
skepticism is only useful
in as much as it leads you to conviction
you keep your mind open you consider
lots of ideas
then you come to a conclusion instagram
did that now does that mean social media
should lose its right to the special
legal protections they have because
they're allegedly not
political because they allegedly don't
make these decisions
good question for federal regulators and
litigators to
take take stock of especially in these
waning days of the trump administration
you know tomorrow night daily wire makes
its entrance
into entertainment content so excited
for this
we have been talking about doing this
since the beginning of the company since
before the company started it's going to
happen tomorrow night
7 pm eastern 4 p.m pacific we will air a
virtual premiere of our first feature
film
run hide fight in a special episode of
backstage
the premiere will stream live over at
the daily wire website
mobile and streaming apps as well as our
youtube channel
after tomorrow's event the movie will be
available exclusively
to daily wire members be aware
run hide fight is not a political film
okay it's not gonna be
some propaganda movie if that's what
you're looking for you're not gonna find
it here
it is intense it is for mature audiences
only
the movie follows a high school sieged
by a quartet
of school shooters when one young girl
17 year old zoe hull
uses her wits and survival skills to
fight back we hope you'll join us for
this special event tomorrow night
that is 7 pm eastern 4 pm pacific at
dailywire.com
apple tv or roku or the daily wire
youtube channel
go become a member if you haven't
already in anticipation of our premiere
tomorrow night we'll be right back with
a lot more
the left is about to get very harsh with
the right
we've been talking about this mostly in
the realm of social media we don't get
to tweet
whatever you know we don't get to post
certain things on the internet
it's going to be a lot harsher than that
you're going to long for the days when
your biggest problem was what you could
and couldn't tweet
and we've been sounding the warning bell
on this for a long time
it's going to involve the sort of
commerce you're allowed to engage in
are you allowed to call an uber are you
allowed to get delivery
food are you allowed to use
certain basic commercial
systems are you allowed to to bank you
know you have a bank right you keep your
money in the bank
some conservatives keep all their money
in their mattress but most i would say
use a bank well
that could come into question not just
for joe schmoe on the street even up to
including
the duly elected sitting president
deutsche bank
made an announcement yesterday said that
they will not
lend to trump anymore president trump
has business holdings all around the
world
trump obviously takes out loans
to grow his businesses and one of those
banks
that he's worked with in the past will
not lend to him
are they not going to lend to him
because he's not a worthy
creditor or a worthy borrower rather
is that it because they don't think
he'll pay it back no i think he'll
probably pay it back
he's the most famous powerful man in the
world at least on paper
his brand has been extremely successful
for decades and decades
i don't think it's that it's because
they don't like his politics
and so they're not going to lend him
money so he's not going to be permitted
to engage in his commerce to grow his
businesses
now you might say well michael look
that's just the beautiful wonderful free
market working
and don't you love that don't you want a
completely unfettered free market with
no regulations
i don't want that i know that a lot of
liberals
seem to think this is a very powerful
argument against conservatives these
days particularly when we talk about
regulating tech
that's not what conservatives believe
that might be what some caricature
of a libertarian from some cartoon in
the 1980s believes but that's not what
conservatives believe
and it's really not what the
conservative tradition has ever
embraced putting that aside for a second
though
i don't want to live in a society where
people's political views
are going to particularly mainstream
political views
are going to completely ostracize them
from engaging in any kind of commerce
but you say deutsche bank has no
obligation to lend trump money okay
if trump doesn't have a right to borrow
money i guess none of us do
does trump have a right to use banking
services
does he have the right to put his money
in a bank
do you have that right do you think
banks should be allowed based on
people's political views
mainstream political views to say we're
going to close your bank accounts
put it under the mattress good luck
probably don't have a lot of fdic
insurance on that mattress but sorry
we're not going to do business with you
i don't think so i don't want to live in
that society that is increasingly the
society that we are
going to be living in signature bank
which is a new york lender that has long
catered to the trump family
is closing two personal bank accounts
in which president trump is holding
about 5.3
million dollars this is according to a
spokesman
not for trump but for the bank
the bank is also calling for the
president to step aside
before his term officially ends on
january 20th
bad enough that hipster rasputin over
there in silicon valley thinks
that he has the right to tell the
president what he can say
and what he cannot say what he can do
and what he cannot do
now you've got a bank in new york a new
york bank
saying we we ought to be more powerful
than the duly elected president
we want him to step aside and we're
going to close his bank accounts
they're not just coming for trump
i i want to dispel this rumor
this this absolute canard that
if some other republican had gotten the
nomination in 2016
first of all that that republican would
have won i'm not sure of that but even
if that republican had would have won
had had one rather
then the left would have gone easy and
the temperature would be lower and
everything would be fine
there were many many articles published
in 2015 and 2016.
with with variations on this headline
everyone's worried about trump but rubio
is much scarier
you're all worried about trump but you
should be much more afraid of ted cruz
mitt romney who's a joke he's a liberal
milk toast
supine submissive
squish for the liberal establishment i
don't know how many more adjectives i
could possibly use
to describe how liberal
republican standards mitt romney is
in in 2012 the president-elect
joe biden said he wanted to put black
people back in chains
in 2012 they said mitt romney was
a homophobic assailant who would clip
the hair of some gay guy in school or
something remember that story
he is so vicious he's such a psycho that
he
put his dog on the roof of the family
car in a cage when he went on vacation
remember that remember that story line
that psycho mitt romney
that maniac who wanted to take his dog
on vacation
who does i would never take a dog on
vacation he's a nice enough guy i don't
even like mitt romney but he's a nice
enough guy that he brings his dog on
vacation
and that is evidence that he's a psycho
they would have done this to any
republican
maybe trump is a little funnier about it
maybe he's a little more of a jerk
about it so he fires them up a little
bit more but in other ways
trump is a little more liberal in his
behavior and in his historical views
in his you know much of his career in
new york he was kind of a more liberal
guy
in some ways they like trump more than
remember they said we we hate trump but
you can't impeach trump because
pence is worse pence is going to
electrocute gays remember that
storyline what was that based on nothing
but that was the way oh you got to watch
out for pence
now because they just turn on any
republicans in office is
got to be the incarnation of evil
you have to say anyone who even possibly
could oppose trump is so much better
which is why they have a strange new
respect for mitt romney or bill crystal
who they used to call a war criminal or
the cheney family i used to call them
war criminals
or pence used to say he was a maniac
electrocuting homosexuals
it's so naive so naive to think that
it's just about trump
it's not about trump they're not after
trump they're after you it's not just
some bank in new york
here's uh here's forbes forbes
magazine says a truth reckoning why
we're holding those who lied for trump
accountable
this is written by randall lane he's the
sort of
adult man who who wears a very silly
looking fedora
so it tells you a lot about him chief
content officer and
editor of forbes he's talking about the
insurrection and the lies and the blah
blah blah kind of
boilerplate democrat talking points but
then he comes to his point
he says that if any
company hires president trump's ex-press
secretaries
ex-spokesman people like kaylee
mcintyny people like sarah sanders
people like
kellyanne conway who would speak for the
president on television
if any firms hire them forbes will
destroy those companies
forbes will take special measures
to try to destroy those companies
because they want these people who
worked for trump
to be unemployable talk about
the patriarchy he's specifically talking
about all these women he says look
ex-press secretaries of the at the white
house they go out and they make a lot of
money guys like ari fleischer or jay
carney and okay that's
fine but we don't want the trump ones to
make money
we want their lives to be ruined we want
them to be completely ostracized from
society
they're not just talking about kaylee
first of all i think ten thousand swords
should leave from their scabbards to
avenge even an insulting glance
at kaylee mcinanny all right but it's
not just about kaylee it's not just
about sarah
it's not just about kellyanne it's about
you
the the forbes content chief content
officer
is coming after you when he's what he's
really saying
the subtext of this column is we don't
want
any of you people who supported trump
any of you 75 million
nazis irredeemable deplorables we don't
want any of you to have a job ever again
we don't want you to be able to vote
ever again we don't want you to be able
to speak
ever again on social media we don't want
you to have anything to do
with society you saw this
from a lawyer at pbs your taxpayer
dollars at work
funding pbs which we know is very
left-wing
i don't know why we fund it if i ever
find myself in a position
of political authority i will
very much look forward to defunding it
but pbs goes out and gets caught up in a
project veritas
investigation james o'keefe speaking
with a principal counsel at pbs
who says not only forget about what
forbes is talking about you know
keep uh trump supporters from getting
jobs ever again
forget about what the banks are saying
prevent trump from
being able to engage in commerce this
pbs
principal council says we need to go to
conservatives
take their children away from them by
force obviously
and then send those children to
re-education camps to make them liberal
and homeland security
and these ties
[Music]
intolerance
we might be gosh in this trump era
we might be raising a generation of
horrible people
not like this guy who is just trying to
take conservatives children away from
them and ship them to
re-education camps even if the democrats
win
now you might say oh he's just mouthing
off at a bar who knows he's just talking
to some undercover person
yeah he's mouthing off at a bar in vino
veritas i guess huh
he doesn't he doesn't seem drunk first
of all i don't even
i don't even know if they're drinking
you might say oh come on it's an
unguarded moment maybe he's joking does
he sound like he's joking to you
shows you another bit talk about naivete
that we're seeing from some of these
republicans
who are sincerely thinking we ought to
impeach trump
there was an argument that was made
before the election they said
look maybe joe biden should win just
bring the temperature down i've i heard
conservative friends of mine say this
and they didn't want to do it they
didn't vote for biden but they're saying
maybe if biden wins it'll bring the
temperature down
it won't it's going to turn the
temperature up
because they're going to get their
revenge and they're going to have the
means to accomplish it and they're
already doing that
it's the same thing with the masks you
hear of i think a very naive argument
from conservatives who go along with the
lockdown measures you know what are we
now like the 320th day to slow the
spread and they say look
i like the mask i wear the mask not
because i think it does very much of
anything
but because the mask if that allows us
to get back to normal society
i'll wear it the mask is not going to
help you get back to some semblance of
normal society
it's going to make things much less
normal it's not going to ease people's
anxieties it's going to
ramp up their anxieties if you go out
and you don't wear the mask
like i have done for basically this
whole time except in the very limited
circumstances where i have to wear a
mask i got an airplane for instance
if you go out and you just don't wear
the mask and you see a lot of other
people not wearing the mask
you're going to be relatively calm if
you go out and you see everybody masked
up like it's the freaking apocalypse
your anxiety is not going to be calmed
it's going to
be greatly increased the temperature is
going
up fortunately pbs fired that guy how
many more of that guy
are there at pbs at the banks
at social media companies at
the mainstream media companies how many
more people are there
you know the temperature has gotten so
high right now
that it is now politically incorrect you
will be ostracized
if you accept the highest civilian honor
in the united states from president
trump
bill belichick who i guess is some sort
of athlete person
i know he's the patriots guy right but i
don't i don't i don't watch a ton of
football okay
and i'm a new yorker so i certainly
don't don't watch the patriots
bill belichick though great american
very impressive guy
he was offered the medal of freedom from
the president
he was very excited he's been friends
with trump for a long time he turned it
down here's a statement
i was recently offered the opportunity
to receive the presidential medal of
freedom which
i was flattered by out of respect for
what the honor represents and admiration
for prior recipients
subsequently the tragic events of last
week occurred and the decision has been
not to move forward with this award
notice the the passive voice here
notice he's not saying i made the
decision he's saying i was pressured
to not accept the award because the
orange man is so bad
because his supporters are so bad
because there are 75 million nazis
in the united states according to the
left
that even the nation's highest civilian
honor
it's too hot can't touch it temperature
is going up folks and they're coming for
you
a lot of this hinges on
very very dangerous ideologies
very very dangerous and stupid and false
premises
but the the premises allow the left to
go very very far
i just read i'm sorry to say a headline
from
hillary clinton in the washington post
hillary rodham clinton the former future
president
quote trump should be impeached but that
alone
won't remove white supremacy from
america
huh white supremacy what does white
supremacy have to do with anything
hillary writes first line wednesday's
attack on the capitol was the tragically
predictable result of white supremacist
grievances fueled by president trump
wait what
i thought it was an insurrection like i
mean that's a
i don't think it was really that either
i think it was an unruly mob
some people though some people there may
have genuinely wanted to overthrow the
government didn't have a plan to do it
but maybe they'd
okay i'm willing to at least entertain
the insurrection word
white supremacist where you get that did
you see clan hoods marching up and down
no
if hillary saw a clan hood at the
capitol she would have hugged it because
she might have thought it was her friend
and mentor robert byrd
white supremacist where you get that
because white supremacist
doesn't mean anything anymore i think at
some point it meant something
doesn't mean anything now it just means
something i don't like in the way that
george orwell
explained that fascism which once i
suppose had a meaning
now just means something i don't like if
you're on the left
people actually use fascists that way on
the right too which i think is kind of
silly
but now on the on the right or on the
left rather you just hear
white supremacist white nationalist
that's all manner of evil the
incarnation of evil white supremacism
and she goes on to stupid op-ed it's not
not even worth wasting our time on the
air
but she says this is the problem the the
capital riot that's just
an expression and we got rid of trump
okay that's just an expression
of the eternal evil here called white
supremacism if white supremacy is really
the big evil shouldn't hillary clinton
have not run for president
shouldn't hillary clinton shut her mouth
she's white
and white's white supremacy is the evil
ultimate evil
so she should stop talking right stop
publishing op-eds is the answer to white
supremacy electing an old white guy
joe biden is he going to fix white
supremacy yeah it doesn't make sense
but this is an ideology that has spread
there was a tick-tock video that just
went viral
of some kooky liberal woman
holding a little baby she's a white
woman all her kids are white
she's holding a little white baby and
she's got two other little white kids
and she instructs her children to kneel
down and worship
black women black women
are the reason that donald trump is no
longer going to be our president
all hail black women
all hail black women you know on
sundays i go to the traditional latin
mass
usually sometimes i have to go to not
latin mass usually it's the traditional
latin mass the smells and the bells the
gregorian chant
and some people say michael that's a
little weird oh man that's that liturgy
is pretty weird
i don't think it's even one one
zillionth
as strange even to outsiders as this
liturgy of liberalism whereby little
children are made
to kneel and worship black women there
are these votive candles these sort of
like you know very religious
iconography all over the candles of
stacey abrams
i seriously it's like peak liberal white
woman is
that sort of a candle but this
is we can laugh about it this is a
dangerous ideology joe biden's pick
for the department of justice's civil
rights division
very very powerful position tucker
carlson broke the story the other day
is a woman named kristen clarke who
while at harvard
wrote a lot of things about kooky racial
theories she said please use the
following theories and observations to
assist you
in your search for truth regarding the
genetic differences between blacks and
whites
at the core of the human brain is the
locus corulius which is a black
structure
because it contains large amounts of
neuromelanin which are essential for its
operation
black infants sit stand crawl and walk
sooner than whites
human mental processes are controlled by
melanin which gives blacks their
superior physical and mental abilities
most whites are unable to produce
melanin because their pineal glands are
calcified or non-functioning
this is the chemical basis for the
cultural differences between blacks and
whites
melanin endows blacks with greater
mental physical and spiritual abilities
something which cannot be measured based
on eurocentric standards
this is the same kooky nonsense that the
actor nick cannon
was talking about he got in a little bit
of trouble though he didn't really lose
his jobs
uh he didn't lose his career at least a
number of months ago
he said melanin melon melanin blackness
that is
the mark of humanity and soul take a
listen
melanin comes with compassion melanin
comes with soul that we call it we call
it soul we soul brothers and sisters
that's the melon in that connection so
the people that don't have it
have are are a lit and i'm gonna say
this carefully
are a little less and and
and and where the term actually comes
from because i'm bringing it all the way
back around okay
to minister to where they may not have
the compassion
or the the when they were sent to the
mountains of caucasus
when they when they didn't have the
power of the sun
that was that the sun then started to
deteriorate with them
the only way that they can act is evil
the only way they can
they have to rob steal rape kill and
fight the flight
in order to survive exactly so then
these people who didn't have
what we had and when i say we i speak of
the
melanated people right they had to be
savages
they had to be barbaric they had because
they're in these
nordic mountains they're in these rough
uh torrential environment
so they they're acting as animals right
so they're the ones that are
actually closer to animals closer to
animals nick cannon could lead the civil
rights division
at joe biden's doj he and joe biden's
actual pick have the same views as
we read in her harvard writings
the left calls all of us nazis because
nazis in common parlance
are the absolute incarnation of evil you
know in christianity we have the
absolute incarnation of good in christ
in secular liberalism modern liberalism
we have the absolute incarnation of evil
and it's just nazis white supremacists
whatever skinheads
and so the left is going to call all of
us that to justify doing whatever they
want to us ostracizing us from society
entirely
preventing us from engaging in commerce
depriving us of civil liberties they're
going to feel good while they do it the
irony is actually
white racial consciousness as measured
by pew is very very low it's about 15
compared to every other race which is
higher than 50 percent
also obviously according to pew uh i i
don't get into the racial identity stuff
this is you know i
the left is really the ones promoting
identity politics
the right generally issues it but what
the left has this special trick here
they're pushing is they decry white
identity politics
while at the same time they foment it
they foster it that is the basis that's
the premise so we can all giggle at
their silly videos and stupid writings
but that is a dangerous situation and
naive republicans should not blame
the right for how ugly american politics
is getting
that blame lays almost entirely
with the left i'm michael moses the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021. on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show